élections municipales les débats
bienvenue bienvenue dans ce débat des
élections municipales et communautaires
2020 sur martinique la première sur nos
antennes radio mais également sur notre
site internet
alors un débat consacré pour cette fois
à la ville de la trinité avec en
principe quatre candidats têtes de liste
qui devrait être en présence dans ce
studio mais on vous dit tout de suite
pour l'heure il n'y en a que 3 et le
maire sortant frédéric duval brille pour
ainsi dire par son absence nous
l'attendions nous l'avons invité comme
les autres dans les mêmes termes
et puis nous n'avons pas eu de réponse
nous signalant une impossibilité ou
voire simplement l'envi de ne pas venir
voilà on nous constatons son absence
mais avec un delivery
nous vous les présente nous vous
présentons sans plus tarder
ceux qui sont bien là en studio
d'ailleurs je vais commencer par richard
bart et derry bonsoir merci d'être là
d'avoir accepté cette invitation
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur livory bonsoir
monsieur qu'à gauche bon soin toutes les
trinitéenne et à tous les trinitéens
bonsoir lamartine vous êtes âgé de 68
ans vous êtes fonctionnaire retraité
vous conduisait la liste unités si
trinitéenne vous présenter comme un
candidat tête de liste sans étiquette
néanmoins vous avez été membre fondateur
de pays où on peut le signaler quand
même on pas du tout pas du tout été
invités seulement j'étais invité
natation comme invité je n'ai pas comme
d'acné d'accord a pour l'instant en tout
cas à vous êtes conseiller municipal
d'opposition déjà la trinité conseiller
territorial est également à ce titre
d'ailleurs président de la saem du
galion à la trinité alors toujours par
ordre alphabétique à nick charles ecc 57
ans cadre dans le secteur du tourisme
bonsoir anne charlotte bonsoir bonsoir à
tous
journaliste richard batellerie les audi
molle tout les trinitéens trinitéenne et
martiniquais qui nous écoutent à vous
êtes aussi une ex responsable de
l'office du municipal du tourisme de la
trinité vous allez mener la liste
trinité à coeur c'est pas ça allianz par
la trinité non pas du tout alliant sport
laiterie malveillance pour la trinité
très bien
pour les aveugles aux gants qui est
faire battre le coeur de la trinité mail
titre de la lune la liste ces alliances
pour la tribu alors vous êtes sont
malades poursuit alliance donc pour la
trinité vous êtes sans étiquette soutenu
par la fédération socialiste de la
martinique et en particulier par louis
joseph manscour l'ancien maire de la
trinité ça exactement troisième candidat
donc en lice est présent dans notre
studio monsieur les olim hall bienvenus
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
aux est âgé de 62 ans cadres supérieurs
d'entreprises publiques notamment
directeur général adjoint de pôle emploi
c'est ce que vous avez été à la trinité
d'ailleurs c'est bien ça et puis donc
vous êtes membre est à la tête de la
liste nouvel élan trinitéen vous êtes
une liste que vous qualifiez de
citoyenne où il a présenté tel quel et
vous vous dites sans étiquette
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur caron soir
monsieur livory bonsoir anik jean alex
bonsoir les charentais loïc booth
bonsoir surtout notre unité est notre
invité l'auditeur de martinique la
première donc on martiniquais voilà non
s'interrogeait faut-il ou non présentées
au frédéric duval mais comme il est en
vie d'à a priori déclaré et peut-être
même dont la candidature a été validée
par la préfecture on ne sait pas
d'ailleurs encore à l'heure on parle
mais on peut le supposer mais en tout
cas même s'il n'est pas là on va
présenter quand même donc succinctement
sa fiche dont il est maire sortant de la
trinité âgé de 70 ans enseignant
retraité il mène la liste dynamique
trinitéenne il est maire depuis 2014
vice-président de cap nord sans
étiquette plutôt sensibilité de gauche
ancien membre de la fédération
socialiste de la martinique est membre
pour frédéric duval pour conclure de
l'alliance ensemble pour une martinique
nouvelle
voilà donc pour la présentation des
candidats en présence pour l'élection
municipale et communautaire à trinité et
maintenant alain ivory vous nous
présenter en quelques lignes la fiche
essentiel de cette ville là l'unité la
ville de la trinité l'une des deux sous
préfecture de lille avec le marin elle
compte douze mille deux cent quarante
trois habitants les trinitéens sa
superficie s'étend sur un peu plus de 45
kilomètres carrés depuis 1945 la trinité
est ancré à gauche avec les maires
successifs et auguste réjean camille
casimir blanc gildor louis joseph
manscour et enfin frédéric duval maire
sortant la ville de la trinité à sur son
territoire la seule usine sucrière
restantes de la martinique il s'agit de
lusine du galion alors comme autres
sites à visiter les aussi le château
dubuc ou encore la réserve de la
caravelle commune de marins-pêcheurs la
trinité à des quartiers célèbres comme
tartane cosmi en ce bel une mais
résignée l'autre bord pour ne citer que
ceux là
j'ai passé les habitants de tartane vont
apprécier qu'on qualifie leur site de
quartier c'est un quartier qui diront
oui comme je sais pas moi on peut
prendre un exemple comme le ps la
commune
c'est un quartier c'est un quartier
c'est un grand quartier c'est pas bon
d'accord voilà pour cette présentation
merci à la et puis l'exercice habituel
maintenant et puis ensuite nous
entrerons dans dans le débat dans l'est
dans les changes entre vous trois
candidats qui est présent mais d'abord
ce micro-trottoir donc réalisé ce matin
dans le bourg justement trinitéen
ou quelques habitants se sont confiés ou
en tout cas ont livré leurs attentes
pour ces élections municipales la grande
majorité que bien que kkr eto'o a
rencontré donc ce matin à temps du
changement notamment pour les jeunes de
cette commune du travail en l'occurrence
pour éviter les rangs c'est la
délinquance on écoute donc ces quelques
sentiments quelques commentaires
recueillis par bianca quartetto je
n'attends rien de ces permis de me dire
c'est pas parce qu'il n'ya pas pour
mourir au travail
moi j'attends beaucoup des choses de ces
élections surtout pour nos jeunes parce
qu'il n'y a rien pour les chaînes ya
beaucoup de chômage je revienne chez moi
là oui j'avais détruit après maison
pickeu ya plus l'armée donc une fois que
les jeux ne sont plus à l'école ils se
retrouvent dans la rue c'est la drogue
c'est la violence etc
après les gens sont déçus les gens ne
vont pas voter particulièrement les
jeunes parce qu'ils se disent bon ben
voilà on ne fait rien pour nous y sommes
la ville elle augmente il faudrait plus
d'activités vous voyez par exemple
samedi soir qui est de l'action parce
qu'on nous sommes jeunes donc parle
plutôt ailleurs pour des fois on se
lamente un range à temps
un maire qui sera visionnaire qui pourra
rassembler tout le monde et ne pas se
cacher dans son bureau et puis prendre
des décisions à la place de l'autre mais
faire avec la population dans le premier
projet que je vois c'est déjà pas
expliquer à la population la réalité
même financière de la commune parce que
on entend beaucoup de projets mais on
n'entend pas les financements les
personnes âgées colovic est un peu pour
par le type vouvet les mêmes têtes
minutes on ne voit personne
voyez le jet d'eau par exemple il
fonctionne plus l'église n'est pas très
joli à l'anc est ce une belle grande
église donc prendre des choses jolies
pour qu'elle soit plus attractive des
fleurs ne parte vous voyez alors vous
l'avez entendu dans ce micro trottoir
les personnes interrogées disent que la
jeunesse et d'issues certains disent
également tous n'iront pas voter donc
risque fort risque d'abstention autre
chose qui revient trinité une ville
morte manque d'attractivité notamment le
soir ils veulent aussi un maire
visionnaire rassembleur qu'il ne fait
pas seul dans son coin mais avec la
population les trinity et veulent
également connaître la réalité
financière de la commune autant de
thèmes qui sont abordés lors de ce débat
mais à chaud quelques recherches avoir
votre vos réactions richard batellerie
le tirage soit vous a désigné pour
commencer quel quelle réaction avez vous
alors c'est extrêmement grave c'est tout
ce que je viens d'entendre de dire quand
un jeune vient vous voir pour vous
demander de lui trouver du travail de
lui donner un emploi il ya toujours moi
une manière de répondre aux gens on ne
répond pas comme ça parce qu'il ya une
certaine souffrance dans ce pays
martinique il ya une souffrance
également à trinité et cinq ans avons
très bien que quand vous êtes maire vous
êtes véritablement le dernier recours
s'il ne trouvait pas de travail serait
jamais allé voir le maire moi j'estime
qu'un que le maire doivent rang
n'accueille particulier il y à il y à il
y a
il y a
une cellule extérieurs à la ville de
trinité qui fonctionnent avec des fonds
propres qui s'appelle ccas le président
du ccas et le maire vincent communal
d'action sociale et le centre communal
d'action sociale action sur ses actions
sociales absolument et c'est le l'état à
travers les communes ont deux voies de
voir c'est un droit du citoyen que de se
rendre dans ce service là non seulement
pas avoir à manger vous savoir comment
manger comment travailler où trouver du
travail je sais c'est l'action sociale
et c'est pour ça que dans mon dans mon
projet la vie sociale au à une par
exemple et à est exceptionnel attendez
richard il ya bien un ccas à trinité
ccas mais c'est bien ce que je dis qui
fonctionne et le président du ccc le
maire c'est pas moi c'est la mairesse ne
joue pas son rôle exact mais non le
seces ne joue pas constater comment le
tuer mais tout ce que je vous pose la
preuve mais vous venez de lancer pas moi
qui les dirigeants qui sont allés voir
le meilleur qui lui-même et représente 1
du ccas qui est le président du ccas
regardez comment il a répondu au jeune
homme ça c'est extrêmement grave c'est
pas moi c'est le jeune homme qui a
raison
alors c'est un ca peut on peut le
prendre en exemple effectivement mais
c'est un témoignage qui a été recueillie
bon voilà pas dire que tous les jeunes
sont accueillis exactement la même façon
richard martinez à je ne sais pas donc
si vous avez des infos sur moi moi je ne
sais pas si le maire accueille tout le
monde comme ça on ne les accueille
moi je m'en tiens aux témoignages que je
viens de rentrer donc voilà votre lit je
m'arrête là seulement je voulais
préciser toutefois une réaction en fait
le micro-trottoir ehrhoff reflète
exactement la situation à trinité on
parle de ville morte
c'est une réalité on parle de ville un
peu délabré pas animé de problèmes de
relations qui sont ressortis entre le
maire et ses administrés et à ce sujet
j'ai envie de dire quand même que même
si je ne suis pas surprise je suis un
peu écuries de l'absence du maire qui a
pris cette habitude de ne pas faire face
à as aux questions de ses administrés
aux questions des journalistes à
répondre aux besoins de ses administrés
moi je trouve pas normal
le maire ne se présente pas pour
défendre bilan et ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas la première fois ce n'est pas la
première fois et en fait il n'est pas
respectueux et je trouve qu'il n'est pas
respectueux vis-à-vis de ces personnes
qui l'ont élu en 2014 aux personnes qui
l'ont porté à ce fauteuil de maire est
en fait aujourd'hui on voit tout
simplement utiles brille par son absence
et vous même qu'elle avait dit il brille
par son absence et envoie ton constat
oui vous avez constaté même s'il brille
par son absence et je partage tout à
fait ce sentiment et nous aurions aimé
new challenger qu'il soit là pour
répondre de ce bilan
mais en tout cas ce micro-trottoir riffs
reflète exactement la situation actuelle
à traîner les olim hall il ya un malaise
un mal-être à trinité il ya un mal être
qui est effectivement comme nous l'avons
entendu le micro-trottoir des peines
tout à fait la situation aux biens bien
sûr nous sommes nous tous ici sur ce
plateau d'accord pour dire que le maire
continue
justement de ne pas respecter sa
population puisque nous l'avons emmené
le micro 3 la manière dont ils
accueillent les personnes
ben son temps liées justement avec la
manière dont il aujourd'hui
il y représente la ville et il se
représente lui même donc oui il y as
malaise à trinité c'est une ville qui
mérite qu'on lui redonne on va dire son
attractivité qu'on lui ordonne on va
dire la nouvelle nouvelle force pour
affronter l'avenir
bien évidemment le présent mérite qu'on
s'y consacre
mais surtout qu'on puisse se projeter
également à l'or lors du micro-trottoir
lumière aussi d'autres thèmes qui ont
été abordés notamment celui de l'église
la reconstruction de l'église et le jet
d'eau monsieur martelly
oui à l'eau ce sont des choix que le
maire fait le meilleur en europe 1 la
mairie de trinité la façade de la mairie
trinité pour 18000 285 euros alors qu'il
y avait d'autres priorités - je
considère que l'église de trinket une
église qui date de 1861 je cois environ
qui est une église qui mérite d'être
d'être
in paris rénové qui m'évite d'être que
nouvelle qui a une façade délabrée où il
ya même des des fougères il ya des
arbustes les pousse sur la façade
moi je crois que ce sont ses priorités
sont pas les miennes il a choisi de
reprendre la mairie qui n'était pas une
urgence qui n'était pas une priorité
au lieu de le d'euros.la l'église de
trinité où il ya même des infiltrations
d'eau je parle sous le couvert de madame
charlet qu'il ya des problèmes
oui parce que madame charles est créé et
plus chrétienne que moi plus pâti comme
que moi je fréquente effectivement je
confirme ce que j'ai dit non mais c'est
très bien non parce que moi je suis
chrétien aussi je ne suis pas pratiquant
donc il ya des témoignages qui donc
c'était donc madame schleck ne peux pas
me démentir sur ça puisque c'est là
c'est là c'est la vérité donc moi je
crois qu'il a fait ce choix là qui n'est
pas le mien
moi je crois qu'il faut faire très
attention c'est une église où justement
dans mon projet dans le projet que je
vais porter nous allons faire en sorte
que cette église las d'une église qui
entre dans le cadre des visites
touristiques de trinité et ça on n'a
jamais fait ça nous allons le faire
il n'est pas question que l'église se
soit aux portes comme ça même si il ya
la séparation de l'état également de de
l'église mais ça nous allons gym
question comme et même si bartoli vous
avez quand même monsieur barthélémy voté
contre le transfert du du du presbytère
voulait préserver lisent mais quand il
s'est agi de du transfert du président
vous avez voté contre pourquoi alors je
n'ai pas voté contre le transfert du
presbytère c'est pas ce qui a été dit je
vous dise que moi j'ai fait donc vous
avez coupé du nom j'écoutais vers vous
les écoutez je suis gay allez-y vous a
écouté mon sont posé la question à l'isi
le maire a fait voter une délibération
il a fait voter une délibération pour
signer un bail emphytéotique de 99 ans
au diocèse de martinique je rappelle ça
veut dire quoi ce véhicule c'est toute
une partie de ses erreurs il sait être
le crès 21
le président jo 16 de la martinique
aucune parcelle tout comme m appartient
à la ville l'église appartient à la
ville monsieur jacques au niveau i
le presbytère appartenait à la ville
mais une délibération qui était prise ou
transférées sur le bail emphytéotique de
80 alors je m'explique j'ai expliqué au
maire et dans le conseil municipal qu'il
ne fallait pas faire ça parce que
c'était le seul espace foncier privé et
public
c'est le bien simple dans le cadre du
bien
privé de la ville le jour où il y aura
son ami ou quelque chose en plus qui est
en hauteur que la ville avait je lui dis
de faire de préférence
il n'a pas ajouté ça à ses amis de faire
ce qu'on appelle une mise à disposition
renouvelables ça se gère ça existe
partout
vous pouvez le renouvelé tous les cinq
ans tous les dix ans à volonté comme ça
de faire renouvellement une convention
signée avec le diocèse pour renouveler
justin justement l'occupation et
l'utilisation de cet espace là mais moi
je ne suis pas du tout contre ça je ne
suis pas du tout contre le disais je
disais qu'il fallait pas c'est qu'on s'y
déroulant kayes et pour vous voir lady
bon me rappelle tellement quand la bima
pas-de-calais la mauvaise et si un jour
nous un caillou je pense que ma
métaphore on la comprend quand même et
là il a déformé pour ses politiques que
ça je le fais le siat mais je maintiens
ce que je dis on ne voit jamais dû
signer un bail emphytéotique pour le
diocèse de martinique
on aurait dû signer une convention de
mise à disposition et un bail
emphytéotique et ça je me tiens ça
mesdames charles avec l'église de la
trinité un thème de campagne
kendo et vous avez je rajoute que vous
avez réagi quand monsieur barthélémy a
dit qu' il avait je crois le projet de
d'en faire un lieu de visite touristique
puisque ça vous parle manger du tourisme
donc effectivement ça fait partie des
projets qu'on avait effectivement
proposait déjà à l'époque par l'office
de tourisme et qu'on avait
à proposer au curé de l'époque les
choses ne sont pas si simple en fait
pour visiter il faut du personnel il
faut effectivement des personnes qui
soient garanties puis il faut mais sur
la proposition et sur le projet je pense
que c'est effectivement une très très
bonne chose d'autant que vous ne la
connaissez peut-être pas mais nous avons
une très très belle église avec des
vitraux originaux où nous avons vraiment
une église qui est qui est très très
belle équipe i un édifice au delà du
culte religieux
nous avons un édifice qui méritent
d'être visités d'être prises en compte
mais j'ai envie de parler du front de
mer parce qu'on a parlé aussi du gedo
dans le dans le milieu pro 3 et ça aussi
c'est important
c'est révélateur du fait que la trinité
soit complètement délabré mérite d'être
rénové on parle du jet d'eau mais on
parle pas de la boule on ne parle pas de
la fontaine aux enfants en fait nous
avons plein de structure d'aménagement
de beaux aménagements qui ont été mises
en place lorsqu'on a aménagé ce front de
mer il te prévu d'avoir de l'eau puisque
nous avons une baie magnifique la
trinité et maritime la trinité s'étale
et s'étire sur une baie dont tous ces
aménagements est avait de l'eau non mais
il n'y a pas il n'ya plus une goutte
d'eau et ben pourquoi qu'est ce qui
explique cela
c'est une vision entretien c'est une
vision une vision globale se donnant les
moyens manquent d'entretien qui opposa
l'on n'a pas de moyens pour les mecs de
l'eau et et et réactiver le jet d'eau on
a de l'eau pde de l'argent pour faire un
boulodrome à 200000 euros
on a de l'argent pour faire une flamme à
au rond-point des marinières à à 50000
euros cre il a attribué le robert 29 +19
on fait le compte
tous les frais épiler 19000 euros de
matières premières ça coûte
excessivement cher
on a de l'argent pour faire ça et on n'a
pas de l'argent pour réparer et rénover
les aménagements du front de mer
voilà quand les jeunes vous dise moi on
a on a fait 1
nous avons fait aussi notre micro
trottoir pour notre programme il ya des
jeunes qui disent parce que cette place
a marqué des générations
elle est construite une presque une
trentaine d'années et aujourd'hui on ne
reconnaît pas la trinité parce que cette
place nous a fait rêver a fait rêver des
jeunes et on a une jeune fille qui nous
a dit on est revenu je suis revenu je ne
connais pas ma trinité je ne reconnais
pas mon front de mer où est ma boule n'a
plus d'eau c'est ce sont des choses qui
marquent
nous sommes obligés ça a l'air banal
pour vous un monsieur d'ivory monsieur
caruge ça a l'air banal mais nous sommes
en train de perdre autres unités
on est face à un problème mais pas tant
et curieux je ne comprends pas pourquoi
de délabrement
on a fait justement alliance pour la
trinité on a sorti un poste on est passé
à trinité une petite visite à trinité
samedi après-midi pour montrer juste des
images éloquentes qui montrent
clairement qu'ils aient un problème
d'entretien et de rénovation qui n'est
pas qu'il n'y pas prise en compta à
trinité particulièrement pour le beau et
laid et les quartiers ne sont pas en
reste parce que quand vous faites un
micro trottoir vous êtes au bout
beaucoup de gens parlent du bout mais
les quartiers attention il faut y aller
un c'est pas c'est pas une sinécure non
plus hein c'est ça des fois on va dans
les campagnes en général les micro
trottoirs sont souvent aux bourdes qui
feront rire mais vous savez il lui faut
remonter au monde parier ans b lune et
vous entendrez d'être idéalement ce
serait de le faire à la fois dans le
bourg et dans des quartiers qu'ils ont
mais des fois on ne peut pas toujours
faute de temps pour les notes cuisine
interne
mais vous avez raison les olim hall oui
allez y aller oui alors d'un voyage est
doué il est bien sûr alors s'agissant de
l'église
effectivement nous avons là un lieu
important de la ville qui date et
surtout qu'ils y sont on va dire d'une
particularité cette église est surmonté
d'un homme qui oppose aux minarets donc
on s'est toujours interrogé de de la
présence de ce minerai en fait j tôt et
j'ai trouvé que l'on fait c'est un
architecte qui en 1930 lors de la
reconstruction a préféré mettre mais
c'est une on va dire un exemple
intéressant de ce qu'il faudrait faire
de qmm peu de fumée du tabac on a pas on
n'a pas tout à fait laver communiste et
contre les religieux à l'église à martin
qui en mina
voilà donc il a expliqué les raisons de
son choix mais en tout cas c'est une
voie là c'est un lieu qui mériteraient
mais qui te battre
on va dire la visite comme d'autres
lieux à trinity d'ailleurs donc bien
évidemment sur la caravelle dans les
quartiers à du ferret par exemple nous
avons un lieu important de la période
on va dire sucrière nous avons dans la
vallée du galion la maison agricole de
la maison du joueur et c'est donc nous
avons pu être le lieu sous lesquels nous
pouvons nous appuyer
mais j'aimerais oui alesi continuer pour
dire que effectivement la présentation
qui est faite par le micro trottoir est
accablante mais j'aimerais insister
également il j'ai bien entendu une dame
âgée dire qu'il y avait un gros problème
et c'est vrai que les personnes âgées
ont un problème de l'accessibilité de
même que les personnes à mobilité
réduite
donc dans la ville de trinité qui se
dégrade hélas comme son nom l'indiqué se
dégrade
elle a perdu déjà du temps mais une
ville qui perd du temps période du temps
pour des années donc il est temps que
nous nous mettions au travail et donc
l'équipe qui m'accompagne est prête à se
mettre au travail pour redresser la cij
en corps une question les olim hall
parce que justement de cette
revitalisation du centre bourg vous en
faites comme comme les autres on l'a
entendu comme les autres candidats le
l'un de vos propositions phares mais
vous allez plus loin vous vous parlez
d'un partenariat public privé pour
relancer en quelque sorte ce centre
bourg bon alors des personnes dans la
classe politique qui se méfie de ce ppp
la partenariat public privé
on a fait de moins en moins vous voyez
par exemple
alors vous allez peut-être d'ailleurs
vous pouvez changer un je vous rappelle
que les aides tous les trois candidats
sur alors évidemment peut-être contre le
maire sortant mais aussi entre vous donc
vous pouvez également échanger vos
arguments bien sûr alors pour clarifier
ma proposition et wilson jeudy que pour
développer leurs activités de la ville
et vous vitaliser et c'est dans le cadre
justement du plan de revitalisation que
je souhaite transformer la ville un an
centre commercial à ciel ouvert qu'est
ce qu'on s'en trouve toute la ville tout
le monde attendait mais je vous
explique qu est-ce que centre commercial
à ciel ouvert c'est simplement une
organisation de la ville des commerces
et de la prestation de service sous le
format de zones commerciales
en fait on ne met pas de dogme si vous
la ville la ville elle-même elle reste
formel et mais on organise le commerce
déloyal à des moyens des moyens de le
faire je constitue en aucun matériau le
temps justement de cette organisation
bien évidemment qui sont les acteurs ce
sont des personnes qui sont des
entreprises privées
donc lorsqu'on organise le commerce
lorsqu'on organise la prestation de
services dans le cadre d'un format qui
pue ça et bien en faisant intervenir des
noms mais sera soit loin là c'est un
partenariat
mais bien sûr et nous allons chercher je
les ai dit non nous allons chercher
autant que faire se peut les
partenariats
ces investisseurs et dont s'il faut
passer par la formule du partenariat
public privé
nous le ferons certains peuvent eux vous
accusez de vendre de carrément la ville
ou privés ce sera toujours voilà au cas
par cas
nous n'allons pas vendre la ville ce
sera une situation au cas par cas pour
faire en sorte que justement ça
s'inscrive dans un un ensemble si on
vous comprend bien pour vous c'est un
outil par jalousie
c'est petit c'est pas une méthode de
travail comme ça pour nous sommes
d'accord systématique sur cet aspect
peut-être parce que c'est la question si
des moyens des financements parce qu'il
ya certaines municipalités qui n'ont pas
les moyens de leur projet et puis ce
disque va finalement oui on est
contraint obligé des fois de se
retourner vers le privé pour pouvoir
réaliser ce qu'on a promis aux quand
vous rentrez dans la ville du françois
il ya tout un fleurissement tout en
embellissant de la ville qui est faite
dans le cadre de partenariats public
privé par un habitant de la ville que
l'on connaît que tous vous vous
connaissez non c'est très très beau
c'est que ça c'est bien ce que ces
exemples on voit ça
voilà par exemple bon ça vous le citez
comment oui je le sais parce que c'est
très rare c'est parce que ça coûte très
très cher et la ville n'aurait pas pu
supporter
cet entretien des dépenses rose
s'agissant s'agissant de l'aménagement
même de la ville faut il faut bien
comprendre une chose c'est que nous
avons une ville madame vient de le dire
nous avons une ville qui est en train de
mourir parce que les commerçants vont
parce que les habitants s'en vont et par
conséquent notre commune n'est plus
attractive ni compétitive c'est pas la
même chose un attractivité et
compétitive de bail différents
l'attractivité c'est le fait d'inciter
les gens à revenir dans leur commune et
la compétitivité de créer aussi des
moyens
il faut qu'il faut des logements il faut
tout ça il faut les inciter à revenir
dans la commune et la compétitivité
s'est donné des exonérations d'impôts
éventuellement parce que c'est faisable
ya des dispositifs pour ça pour inciter
les acteurs économiques
nous avons un bassin d'emploi qui à la
zone du bac dans le projet
nous avons l'intention nous allons faire
en sorte qu'il y ait une extension sans
toucher à la forêt la cus que nous avons
juste à côté qui est une bulle là fouet
il faudrait la cus qui est unique en
martinique il y en a une en guadeloupe
dans la zone de jarry j'ai pas pour ceux
qui connaissent qui fait 30 38 ans on a
une qui faisait 20 ans qui fait neuf
hectares actuellement sans y toucher
nous allons faire une extension pour
permettre aux acteurs économiques de
revenir sur trinité sang et par
conséquent sans me faire l'avocat du
maire qui nique et absent il a quand
même dit que il y a eu le retour des
chefs d'une centaine de chefs
d'entreprise une installation d'une
centaine d'entreprises sur le territoire
monsieur monsieur niveau je me baladais
jeu nous a sonné l'indien et voir et
vous émettez c'est ce que la trinité
c'est la ville la journée festive jean
yves de mardi pouvait décemment pas
monsieur paris qui les jo des cochons
le maire a répondu ça il a posé un homme
d'état il a dit ça voilà je vais je vais
vous dire comme une trinité qui perdent
des commerces régulièrement on avait une
grande enseigne de librairies que vous
connaissez très bien qui est affronté la
france qui est partie est la voie la
somme on avait également un opérateur
téléphonique qui nous a laissé et par
conséquent ça c'est extrêmement grave
je tiens à rappeler qu'il y a une grande
enseigne à la zone du bac et justin sur
les côtés où il y a un maire du nom qui
est prêt à lui donner un terrain qu'ils
viennent s'installer
le jour où il laisse savez très bien de
qui s'agit le nom ses commencements b le
jour où il s'en va c'est un moteur
économique dans la zone le jour où il
s'en va la zone est morte et par
conséquent le risque existe selon vous
c'est ce que voudrait bien sûr y a des
attendez attendez mais bien sûr que
loris et j'en attendais mais je termine
je termine monsieur ko si vous permettez
je suis donc il faut que notre ville
soit compétitive et il faut qu'elle soit
attractif donc nous nous allons tout
faire pour que justement les acteurs
économiques reviennent sur nous avons
l'intention de construire quatre quatre
ou cinq ou six kiosques à l'entrée
d'autres unités pour réanimer comme ça
existe à cet maria la zone de la place
clarisse a fait en sorte que des acteurs
économiques plus animer la ville de
façon à ce que les gens puissent revenir
parce qu'une ville qui ne vit pas la
nuit
on ne va pas dire ouvert vers toute
l'année même ce risque des gens qui vous
allez prendre une bo moi j'ai une
brochette ou bien prenons impôts est une
ville mans trinité en ce moment c'est
une ville dont toi d'ailleurs c'est ce
que l les villes dont toi là et ça c'est
que c'est mauvais alors c'est ce que
qu'une jeune a dit non mais je veux
revenir sur l'intervention et le
témoignage d'une dame personnes âgées
qui dit il n'y a rien là encore il y à
ce devoir et cette obligation de prendre
en compte ces personnes de cet âge d'un
certain âge qui ont besoin d'un
accompagnement et nous aussi dans notre
projet pour une trinité citoyenne et
solidaire
nous prévoyons effectivement de les
accompagner avec des choses qui paraît
simple mais qui sont essentiels à mettre
en place avec un service
lo gran moun par exemple même dit oui
bon qu'on vienne les voir j'ai bien
entendu ce qu'elle a dit 30 minutes
discuter nous avons prévu effectivement
le service à la personne
a lo gran moun et les accompagner nous
avons aussi prévu de mettre en place au
clsh à l'instar de ce qui se fait pour
les enfants
centre de loisirs sans hébergement pour
les personnes âgées
ça aussi il faut penser aux loisirs pour
il faut penser à les accompagner et moi
j'ai été très sensible aux témoignages
de cette personne qui a réagi aux à
votre micro trous 3 et je veux rebondir
également sur des questions que vous
posez concernant le ccas puisqu'il
s'agit de social on est en train de
parler de personnes âgées
notre ccs est aussi en train de son
entrain de se poser des questions le ccs
avait un outil un bel outil au service
de l'insertion de l'accompagnement des
jeunes des familles en difficultés des
familles monoparentales des familles
vraiment en difficulté
c'était la maison de la famille et de la
parentalité et cette maison actuellement
il faut passer je vous invite à passer
sur la rocade d'aller vers sainte marié
vous allez voir que cette maison qui a
été inauguré en 2014 2014-2017 début
2015 est aujourd'hui pratiquement à
l'abandon en fait le 3 est enlevée on
est en train de se poser des questions
le personnel est aujourd'hui toujours du
centre d'action sociale je parle du
centre communal d'action sociale qui
avaient qu il y a à sa disposition au
président un outil il a rappelé deux
fois sa manucure un outil stratégique
pour ce service public qui y est cette
maison de la parentalité de la famille
de la pente parentalité aujourd'hui une
maison je vous le rappelle qui a été
financée à 80% pour la caf mais qui ne
concerne pas seulement que les
trinitéens les familles trinitéenne mais
qui concerne aussi les familles du nord
aujourd'hui j'aurais voulu vraiment
comme monsieur le maire soit présent le
maire sortant soit présent ou 12 lgt qui
les tarifications pour nous expliquer
aujourd'hui pourquoi les agents qui sont
normalement en poste dans cette maison
de la famille de l'un parentalité se
trouve aujourd'hui entassés dans une
dans une salle de réunion
pinceaux alors monsieur libéraux
il reste un quart d'heure de
démissionner rapidement est ce que
monsieur l'ip monsieur nintendo pour
relancer l'attractivité de la commune
est ce qu'il faut mettre fin aux
papillons péan au centre bourg non il
faut effectivement organiser le
stationnement dans la ville
aujourd'hui il me semble que le saint
saturnin n'est pas payant donc pour des
raisons on va dire de moyens financiers
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a également une
société qui gère les parkings il me
semble qu'il ya un contrat qui doit
aller à son terme
donc il faut organiser les choses donc
c'est pas tellement si ou ça que moi
j'ai envie de rester
c'est quand même aussi pour lui mais
lorsque je dis que nous allons organiser
le commerce ou les glissières puissance
nous allons le faire leur salon de faire
nous allons le faire avec 200 nous
allons le faire avec et par les
conversions la vocation de merde n'est
pas de faire la place de révocation du
maire est d'accompagner l'on vous c'est
ce qui a été fait là quand on a installé
les bornes pour faire payer etc
sap a été fait avec un géant
concertation léger retrouve de la place
j'ai retrouvé des documents qui laisse
penser qu'il y a eu un moment une
concertation mais qui n'a pas abouti
telle qu'elle aurait dû d'accord donc ça
aboutit à ce que nous avons comme
résultat en tout cas moi ce que je
voudrais dire et par rapport toujours et
enfin et le mérite absent de toute façon
on va pas parler une pièce vide
ce que je souhaite dire que à propos de
notre projet c'est que lille où il
réunit justement les préoccupations
enfin il répond aux préoccupations de ce
qui s'est dit garantir le bien vivre
ensemble liens intergénérationnels
accompagner le développement économique
mais je les dis est vrai pour la
préservation de l'environnement et la
valorisation du patrimoine jour en le
laissant en héritage en 2004 vision à
l'aréna de l'émission mais bon je vais
quand même le dire en introduction
parce que nous allons ben oui je
souhaite dire que oui cette ville
c'est une belle ville on nous le dit
tout le temps et toutes les personnes
qui ont connu trinité se sont désolés de
voir dans quel état elle se trouve donc
et ils y allaient des préoccupations qui
s'expriment lorsque nous allons dans les
quartiers lorsque nous allons dans la
ville disent à peu près tout la même
chose cette ville a perdu de sa superbe
et sel n'est pas propre
elle n'est pas belle il faut l'embellir
il faut réorganiser les choses
il faut de l'ecoute pour que la
population puisse s'exprimer et
d'ailleurs nous sommes un mouvement
citoyen sur le gazon notre action sur la
participation et la participation
n'avons pas affaire après nous l'avons
fait dès le début de la pré campagne et
nous vous suivons nous ont dit nos
travaux dans ce cadre là c'est comme ça
que nous avons justement les retours de
la population qui nous disent que nous
allons dans le bon sens bon je voulais
juste revenir sur le stationnement
payant avec mon ex mari richard bart et
d'eric s'exprimer avec mon équipe
non parce qu'il ay l'aï laissée il
intervenu dessus moi je voulais juste
dire une chose c'est que là ils sont en
train de changer ça fait deux ans qu'il
n'y a pas de stationnement payant sur la
voie 1 sur l'axé principal de la ville
lorsqu'ils sont entrés de le transférer
pour le maître comme pau passe au disque
bleu et jusqu'à besoins sont incapables
de le faire je sais pas pourquoi ils ne
louent pas enfin que nous pensons qu'il
ce qu' il
le maire de trinité et son équipe le
maire de trinité et sa majorité
jusqu'à présent ils n'ont pas encore
réglé ce problème là mais je vous
rappelle pour avoir visité les
commerçants à plusieurs reprises ils
sont pour le stationnement payant à
trinité exit chaîne ils ne veulent pas
que l'on supprime le stationnement
payant alors y aller parc enclos qui
fonctionne très bien avec avec les
pièces mais sur la voie il n'y a plus de
stationnement payant et il avait
institué à l'époque de monsieur le
meilleur précédent
tout simplement pour permettre qu'il y
ait une terre nos voeux pour permettre
aux voitures de tourner parce que des
gens sont en tête du nord garer leur
voiture ou dans l'axé principal de la
ville de trinité et point n'est le taxi
pour descendre à fort de france donc
c'est dans cet esprit là qu'il avait
richard zanuck la situation si cela il a
quand même fait quelque chose de bien le
maire sortant le maire sont financés par
le médecin n'est pas candidat monsieur
nous et c'est pas le maire sortant qui
est candidat c'est monsieur duval qui
est candidat c'est pas le maire sortant
je suis buval partir d'aujourd'hui c'est
bien sûr c'est pas le meilleur c'est
palau trois maires des daaf
secours à van avant qu'on ait quand même
on peut pas ne pas parler de la trinité
sans parler sans évoquer la pêche mais
il faudra aller très vite
donc cette activité économique aussi
mais tient comme vous avez parlé non
vous avez la parole mais je vais la
donner à un échec mais quoi vous avez
évoqué le prédécesseur de frédéric but
valable ou non expliqué paul estimé la
station et du coup vous l'avez évoqué
oui bon sens le hainaut mais sans le
nommer mais finalement la nommer louis
joseph manscour il y a 6 ans avait pour
ainsi dire désigné monsieur buval comme
son successeur aller jusqu'à dire son
dauphin oui entre temps il ya eu
beaucoup d'eau dans le gaz
et voilà que pour 2020 officiellement il
vous soutient annick charles heck
l'ancien maire de la trinité
louis-joseph pour tout à fait tout c'est
encore le cas là alors que la campagne
officielle commence on sait jamais non
c'est l'homme qui a changé d'avis oui je
vous confirme je vous confirme qu'il me
soutient qu'il soutient l'équipe
alliance pour la trinité et jeu j'ai
bien envie de dire qu'il a fait le bon
choix qu'il a fait le bon choix parce
que effectivement vous avez dit à 6 en
il ay live moi j'ai voté monsieur
boucher voulez que je vous fasse une
évidence j'ai voté monsieur buval j'ai
voté frédéric duval ça me donne
l'occasion de dire que je vais à ces
élections je m'engage
mais je n'ai rien contre monsieur duval
j'ai voté frédéric duval pour les
cantonales j'ai voté frédéric duval
parce qu'effectivement vous dites un
dauphin qui l'avait évité un petit peu
mais je suis déçu comme beaucoup de
trinité 1
nous avons été déçus comme monsieur
moscow vous parler d'eux dans le gaz
émis par les d'eau dans le gaz j'ai
juste envie de dire que nous sommes
déçus 2 de l'action municipale sur les
années et j'aurais beaucoup aimé que le
maire sont en soit là pour qu'ils nous
entendent et partage avec nous ses
éléments de milan qui vous connaît ma
télé moderne charles monsieur est ce que
ce n'est pas
la vengeance d'un homme blessé et
héliporté monsieur mais vous m'avez posé
une question c'est quand même gros de
continuer cette tonalité depuis le début
de parler de vengeance
comment aujourd'hui encore après des
mois de campagne
on peut continuer à parler de vengeance
ça veut dire que je n'existerais pas je
serai complètement transparente
j'ai envie de parler de misogynie chaque
fois que je me retrouve dans les médias
on me parle de monsieur moscou je serais
vous seulement 2,9 en jean mais vous
même et vous c'est une question mais ce
n'est pas qu'une question en fait sous
jacent derrière ça il y à cette espèce
de spectre que vous brandissez chaque
fois que je serai sombré ce ruban vous
avez l'air d'un instrument jeu est ce
que j'ai l'air de nos magazines en fait
en fait en fait il faut arrêter parce
que vous pour lui le des bars en fête
vous les journalistes à parler comme ça
et à parler d'ailleurs je vous conseille
quelque chose à dire invités béatrice
bel et buvaient et monsieur mon secours
comme ça vous aurez toutes les réponses
ce sens peut-être le cas parce que parce
que la réalité c'est que je suis en
incapacité de vous répondre sur l'eau
dans le gaz et sur les problèmes de
vengeance où boudouda
j'ai dit j'ai décidé de m'engager je
n'en suis en aucun cas blessés je suis
fier de mon engagement est aujourd'hui
monsieur mon secours a décidé de
m'accompagner
le reste des blessures ou autres je ne
les connais pas et de grâce arrêtez un
hôtel en attendant sentiment nouveau
châssis ce geste parce que ce n'est pas
la première fois non c'est pas vrai
métier sur ça on vous
la révélation la voulez pas ça vous
poseront les questions que nous
souhaitions posée quelle plaie et
qu'elle dit est ce que j'avais et je
répondrai venant vols aller jusqu'au
bout et j'aurais bien que c'est une
petite tonalité de misogyne non mais
vous vous trompez pas du tout fonctionné
lors été un homme nous aurions posé là
même qu'elle a la chance de roue et son
genre qui soutient une femme mais j'en
doute genre histoire
alors maintenant je serai jamais faisant
des choses aux aînés qu'ajouter au
délicat mais je fais mon métier et je ne
dors je alors comprendre rapidement déjà
les coui ça constitue aussi un enjeu
particulier pour la fédération
socialiste pense que quand même la
trinité a été depuis 1945 socialiste
parce que c'est le bastion quand même de
deux socialistes nationalisme martinique
est ce que là pour la fédération
socialiste qui vous soutient est-ce que
7,7
comme à dire cette élection constitue un
enjeu particulier mais probablement mais
pourra poser la question madame b les la
première fédérale et je trouve que c'est
une très bonne quel dommage je ne donne
pas l'image la salle je suis soutenu par
un parti
defacto parce qu'il ya un éléphant un
poids-lourd monsieur moscou qui
m'accompagnent je ne peux pas être la
voie de la fsl monsieur vie laurie
livory si vous êtes journaliste vous
pouvez le comprendre
effectivement je peux pas être la voie
de la fsl qui a invité madame des listes
elle nous met invité madame bel et elle
va vous répondre mais je pense
effectivement la trinité bastion
socialiste on a effectivement la madame
bailey va vous le dire mais ça s'est
passé
où est ce que je veux partager avec vous
c'est mon engagement pour la trinité ce
que je veux faire pour la trinité le
reste c'est pas ce n'est qu'à la marge
en fait encore ses accessoires
moi je crois que non seulement je me
concentre que le départ de l'unité sur
l'ancien maire et ça ça me gêne un peu
il n'est pas là
les observateurs non sur l'enseignement
secours oui mais c'est du soutien de
l'ancien maire qui est toujours là qu'il
ya peu de temps qui était député
européen et il aurait pu lui apporter de
soutien à personne noire vous monsieur
barthélémy ont été encore plus
surprenant mais il a apporté à madame
charles labrecque mais il a la gouaille
de toi c'est tout donc on pose la
question à partir de ça maintenant nous
avons d'autres questions pour vous d'un
autre ordre
les moi moi je voulais juste
revenir non non moi je sur le sur
l'album photos du maire sont vous n'avez
pas tout l'album photos du bien aux
autres
vous avez des questions à lui poser en
page 10 impasse je sais quoi c'est un
album qui élaguent en photo depuis 2001
voilà juste que nous sommes sur le net
voilà le bilan du maire le bilan faut
que ce film est le bilan photo du maire
dit vivre un saut d'humeur à la pince 10
et à la page 16 il est allé deux mêmes
photos à la page 16 et à la passe il y a
deux mêmes fautes vu aussi à la page 14
il ya la fête du chromebook j'adore le
col boule ma mère est une indigène ça ça
mérite un jane ma mère est une adjet et
ma mère fait très bien le col la fête du
col bout contre la fée vous non j'adore
là j'adore le colt oui mais le mais le
met a fait la recette
oui mais moi j'aurais été notre page la
trinité c'est la capitale du trempage
dont je respecte ça je respecte ça moi
même gaffe moyen terme à chaque semaine
d'accord c'est pas la même chose mais là
a fait du col beau ça me surprendrait
pas ce que c'est aux égéries
nous l'avons fait la fête du col bout
nous l'avons fait dans toutes les pages
et presque toutes les pages ont des
photos un double non je crois qu'il faut
arrêter avec ça et une fois la campagne
terminée je saurai quoi faire très bien
et puis on va on va en venir aux
conclusions
oui je pense que nous avons été menés
nous avons été piégés parce que nous
avons nous apitoyer aussi voit la
situation du maire sortant
là j'ai envie de parler de nos projets
seulement c'est peut-être le moment de
le dire j'en profite
moi j'ai envie de dire que en dehors de
de l'attractivité de la ville en dehors
des problèmes d'embellissement de la
ville il y a effectivement le problème
de la gestion et de la performance de la
ville et vous ça j'ai envie de redonner
confiance au personnel municipal pour
garantir une bonne qualité de service on
l'a vu dans le micro trottoir
les gens se plaignent de ne pas avoir
une bonne qualité de service et donc il
faut redonner confiance au personnel
municipal
je souhaite nous l'avons dit mobiliser
les fonds nécessaires
peut-être passer par la formule du
partenariat public privé mais en tout
cas mobiliser les fonds aussi des autres
collectivités ctm cap nord et à gilles a
sous les yeux
les catalogues de moyens pour obtenir
des subventions à tous les niveaux donc
c'est possible de mobiliser des fonds
pour pouvoir faire en sorte que la ville
puisque outre ils font ce qu'on voit la
force européenne donc europe et puis les
jeunes les jeunes je veux faire le fait
dévier une ville connectée et quand je
le dis hier où il travaille est un jeu
présenté
elle est connectée elle n'est pas
connectée mais laissez moi vous dire
comment nous allons la connecter
lors de ma présentation de listes nous
étions en direct facebook et dans le
reste du monde a pu constater que nous
étions connectés et donc nous avons ça
signifie crois ça signifie que lorsque
vous allez rentrer à trinité sont en
sortant de lestrade et que vous preniez
le rond point avant de rentrer dans la
pratique à lyon et bien vous allez
pouvoir voir sur votre smartphone
s'afficher vous entrez à trinité et
voilà ce que vous allez trouver à
trinité à gauche à droite au centre de
l'aventuré pour de la réalité
voilà de telle sorte que les gens les
touristes ou les visiteurs ne puisse pas
nous poser la question comme ça m'est
arrivé de répondre à plusieurs reprises
à des personnes il savait l'animal
comment s'orienter
vous avez
vous n'avez pas parlé de la pêche des
marins pêcheurs vous avez quelque chose
bien sûr à lens de l'émission pour nous
après sont présents alors pour les
marins pêcheurs
alors les marins pêcheurs nous avons à
trinité une école d'apprentissage
maritime
nous avons une belle madame charlotte
l'a dit nous avons donc on avait une
vocation maritime
nous voulons à la fois que les maréchaux
piste travaillé en tant que marque
deschamps n'était plus aussi diversifier
leurs activités
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
proposerai que nous finissions des
balades dans la baie or ça existe déjà
dans la baie de notre père fernand louis
labatut raison ce poteau il faudrait que
nous ramenions ses activités dans la
baie de trinité par exemple et puis les
marais pichot notamment ceux de tarnac
et de cosmic vieillissent ya besoin que
nous puissions organiser la transmission
du savoir
alors transmission du savoir sur la
partie traditionnelle mais peut-être
aussi souriante et se projeter vers une
pêche un peu semi artisanale pour que
les bulles marie puchon qu'il puisse y
trouver le moyen de vivre et de faire
vivre nos familles et vie dernière chose
tout ce que nous allons faire vont être
va nous permettre de fournir de l'emploi
je suis aux professionnels de l'emploi
je ne souhaite que les trinités
n'hésitez donc qui sont assez nombreux
en termes de chercheurs d'emploi
puissent avoir des opportunités d'emploi
donc tout ce que nous ferons devra
déboucher sur un an prépare à 6,1 après
par la foule et personnes âgées pour les
jeunes la connectivité la ville etc
tout devra faire en sorte que l'activité
permettent à des jeunes de s'insérer
voire de se former au passage
alors madame charlet que sur ceux douchy
pêche emploi jeunesse
quelles sont vos propositions alors sur
la pêche effectivement on a on a la même
vision des choses concernant la
diversification de l'activité
on a une commune qui est holistique mans
bien pourvus donc on a une autre saison
qui on va dire très belle il faut
permettre à nos marins pêcheurs de
diversifier leurs activités de proposer
des choses simples emmener en balade les
touristes à lever les nazes
beaucoup de scènes à la pêche au gros
c'est des petites initiatives comme ça
individuels comporter du fruit donc
santana leur salaire peut être banal
mais il faut aider nos pêcheurs nous
c'est possible ces personnes à
diversifier leurs activités mais j'ai
envie de parler aussi des agriculteurs
puisqu'on en parle pas beaucoup en
parler de fond on parlait de
l'utilisation de fonds de financement
il y a effectivement le fait à dr caylar
on a plein de fond de ligne qui ne
trouvent pas de projet kilkis et qui
repart des terres disponibles il y a des
choses qui ceux qui peuvent être faites
même sur des petits espaces dans la
diversification dans et puis accompagner
les êtres les agricultures sur 7 sur
cette diversification
aujourd'hui la trinité de cette unité a
été aussi touché aussi par le
chlordécone
ici aussi les tentations à lanières sur
la commune même mais aussi sur les coen
non plus mais c'est aussi un puisqu'on
parlait de pêche là on a retourné mais
il faut aider aussi parce que cette
problématique qui vraiment qu'ils
existent vêtements ne doit pas tuer
notre agriculture
donc quelque part il faut accompagner
parce que ce sont des enjeux majeurs
aujourd'hui il ya des choses à faire
l'aviculture ne va pas se résumer à ça
et puis à dieu les terres sont
chlordécone est donc on ne peut plus
rien faire
il faut accompagner et muté vers autre
chose qui permette d'avoir effectivement
des cultures alors il faut il faut mais
est ce que vous avez prévu un plan enfin
des moyens pour ça que je vous ai parlé
ses arrières
il y avait une question mais s'il se
sent très juste après voilà en fait il y
avait effectivement des fonds il faut
des projets il faut une certaine et
généreux il faut aller voir les
agriculteurs il faut enquêter pour
savoir exactement leurs besoins est allé
sur ces lignes qui sont proposés et
faire des projets proposés des projets
aujourd'hui alors on ne reparle le maire
sortant n'est pas là mais en six ans on
n'a pas mobilisé 1 euros des fonds
européens
ce sont des choses qui nous qui sont un
peu mais c'est ahurissant
s'interroge sur le pourquoi des choses
vous avez dit que pendant six ans
l'équipe là qui étaient en place n'a pas
elle fait en sorte de mobiliser de livia
il y a eu des fonds aux pays riches ont
été mobilisés mais sur des projets de la
mandature précédente
mais je parle de projets qui sont sortis
pour mobiliser pour nouveaux projets
nécessitant c'est ça c'est ça la réalité
et rire est la situation financière
justement puisqu'on parle de finance
quelle est la situation financière de la
ville justement monsieur martelly
merci met ainsi sur le compte
administratif 2010 8 puisque nous sommes
en 2020 nous n'avons pas encore voté le
compte administratif 2010 9 je compte
administratif il y avait un déficit il y
avait un déficit d'un million quatre
cent mille euros à la ville de trinité
savez quand vous avez sur un budget vous
avez une section d'investissement sur
chaque ligne de recettes sur chaque
ligne de dépense les lignes de recettes
une ligne de dépense l'une des sept
lignes de dépenses on line de recettes
et quand tu les lignes de dépenses vous
n'avez plus de lignes de recettes vous
entrez dans le déficit de la ville de
trinité et 1 2 million cent mille euros
sur la section d'investissement en
déficit
et ça le maire ne l'a jamais dit quand
il l'envoie d'ailleurs aux conseils
municipaux quand il tient justement le
budget que l'on vaut que le compte
administratif c'est à vous de prendre
vos calculettes de faire la différence
pour savoir quel est le déficit de la
vie heureusement cela vous pas l'unicité
de dieu si difficile déséquilibre budget
de déficit et 2 2 millions 102 millions
250 mille euros environ et ce sera
beaucoup plus musclé l'a fait 80% de son
projet à noter qu'il a fait 80 qui n'a
pas fait 80 brossât j'ai l'impression
qu'ils se trompent qui les versent un
petit peu les les choses donc moi quand
je vais arriver aux affaires je vais
embaucher un conseil cabinet conseil
d'auditeurs vous faire un audit
financier
un audit du personnel et un audit du
matériel et en plus j vais même plus
loin je vais demander aux auditeurs de
me faire une analyse financière et
l'analyse financière va bien plus beau
elle tient compte des cinq dernières
années
c'est à dire que si vous avez perdu des
commerces sur les cinq dernières
année elle se projette également sur les
cinq prochaines années et vous avez une
photographie un petit peu financière de
ce que vous pouvez faire une fois que
nous aurons mis en place cet audit
financier nous allons informer le préfet
nous allons confirmer la chambre
régionale des comptes nous allons
informer la population sur la situation
financière de la ville
je la connais mais si je la fais si on
l'a fait nous mêmes une fois arrivé au
pouvoir
ça n'a pas de sens on va dire que
c'était partisans c'est donc cabinet
d'audit heures va nous le faire et
rassurez vous je sors et je saurai
diffuser l'information
alors concernant la pêche je voulais
juste dire deux mots à trinité
actuellement il ya environ 65 marins
pêcheurs il ya cinq ans il y en avait 80
90 donc le nombre de marins pêcheurs
diminue pas vraiment peau de chagrin les
communes fait ce sont ces données que le
patient nicole séducteur et les
enseignants eux mêmes sous les moissons
l'appelle comme ça donc moi j'essaie de
respecter l'école l'apprentissage c'est
important de vous et vous avez raison il
ya soixante cinq marins pêcheurs
actuellement il ya trois types de pêche
à martinique il ya la pêche miquelon
c'est la dépêche lointaine il a la pêche
côtière et à la pêche à la senne la
pêche côtière et la pêche à la senne il
faut mettre une croix dessus
lorsque l'on n'est plus adéquat à cause
du chlordécone
il ya plein chlordécone qui va sortir je
vais le suivre savons exactement ce
qu'ils peuvent voir
donc il ne reste que la pêche miklos et
damien poche lointaines en france qu'en
seulement quelques jours au large outre
elle a nominé péché ne sont pas formés à
cette pêche là il faudra les former une
nouvelle mode ici non plus at-il fallu
pour ça
j'ai compris je connais pas je n'ai pas
le même niveau de compétence vous pouvez
dans mon projet ce que je deviens de
guillaume sait pas que c'est la
répétition qui permet de comprendre les
choix semblent aimer non c'est qu'on
analyse bien la scène des situations
qu'on va au moins la pêche on est
d'accord mais je me lâche tout ça et ça
je vais le faire parce qu'il ya des
dispositifs concernant mes fonds
européens comme aller retour vous
pourriez vous entendre si la deuxième
tour voyez moi et moi et moi j'ai un
jour je joue les matches les uns après
les autres le match aller d'abord le
match au tour ensuite
non mais je crois qu'il ne faut pas que
je me mettais je ne suis pas comme
certains candidats du françois
ça va se mettre déjà deuxième émission
va se terminer
monsieur martelly un petit peu de temps
de pas d'avoir ça c'est ce que me
signale je sais tu apprends votre
collègue chargé de recenser l'aller à la
conclusion que pour vous c'est terminé
d'un débat là avant c'est extrêmement
important pour moi de parler d'un
problème de cette collectivité de
l'administration communale de trinité il
y à vraiment le départ des cadres qui
est effarant
en moins de quatre ans en moins de
quatre ans non mais c'est une réalité
c'est ahurissant il souffre ans du
personnage une souffrance réelle du
personnel qui fait y compris des cadres
apparemment des calques mptic et virtual
arcade
à la veille de la campagne puissant il
part contraint et forcé de la soie pâle
c'était très important c'est dommage de
soirée de relationnel mon image
attachement on parle on parle de
problèmes de mépris on parle de
problèmes de problèmes de respect on
parle de problèmes de respect de cette
administration communale et ça il faut
le relever il ça il faut que les
trinitéens et puis que vous aussi que
quand vous faites vos micros trop trois
peut-être qu'il faut aller voir ici
parce qu'il y auras tu auras peur de
paraître beau foot et la réalité c'est
ça posez vous les bonnes questions et on
aurait aimé savoir que monsieur le maire
nous réponde sur sur cette question
pourquoi nos cadres s'en vont pourquoi
nous avions un directeur général des
services de poids de qualité une
intimité tribune et qu'il est parti
la fuite des cadres 7 problème
révélateur de cette collectivité de
cette collectivité c'est pas ton c'est
pas tant il y a un réel problème
aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons pas l'eau à
la veille d'une campagne officielle le
cadre démissionne comment comment que ça
veut dire quoi ça ça veut dire quoi
remonter à trinité et puis poser des
questions à traiter
je voulais savoir s'il avait encore une
question à poser à léo l'immoler parce
qu'on va passer ensuite ses conclusions
c'est la dernière occasion ça signifie
qu'il reste du temps c'était ça il vous
reste pas beaucoup de temps non mais
c'est la dernière occasion d'aller au
niveau risque de poser une question mais
manifestement il vraiment puisque ma
parole je dis que nous sommes dit pas
plus mais nous sommes d'accord sur les
constats nous sommes tous d'accord sous
les constats avec la population dans le
cadre du micro trottoir
on l'a vu nous sommes d'accord sur les
conséquences la ville est en train de
perdre de son attractivité de sa superbe
donc maintenant il s'agit de parler des
projets nous avons pu trinité une
ambition dans le cadre de cette campagne
électorale nous développons notre
ambition qui consiste à faire en sorte
que grâce à la nouvelle attractivité
pour retrouver la ville de trinité
puisse doivent redevenir une ville
championne parce que nous étions une
ville championne à travers le sport à
travers le commerce que le sport toutes
les activités linguistiques patrimonial
culturel
nous étions champions donc je veux
redonner de la fierté à la ville de
trinité pour qu'elle redevienne une
ville d'une championne
et vous ça nous avons des projets nous
avons bien sûr alors un programme garder
un peu sous le pied à la conclusion que
l'on en arrive je suis respectueux
voilà richard bartoli va commencer vous
avez une minute pour vous adresser
directement donc aux électeurs et à ceux
qui vous écoute et vous regarde là et
vous regardons également oui à l'heure
d'internet je m'adresse aux trinitéen je
leur dis que le moment du changement a
sonné nous voulons à unity trinitéenne
nouvelle trajectoire politique ou la
ville de trinité nous voulons que les
choses changent
j'y vais très très loin en disant que
trinité n'a pas besoin de joueurs
d'habitation trinité a besoin d'eux mais
qu'ils soient au plus près au plus près
de sa population
voilà ce que nous voulons pour trinité
moi je dis que dans les conditions
actuelles
trinité ne peut pas avoir meilleur comme
celui-là on ne peut pas remettre aux
affaires le meilleur comme celui là qui
naquit à beaucoup de condescendance par
rapport à la population et s'enlever pas
et je vais terminer par une phase en
disant que le monde
c'est une phrase de georges kettling qui
dit le monde a peur du changement
et pourtant c'est la seule chose qui
permet de progresser georges ketting est
un inventeur noirs américains voilà
c'était la conclusion de richard bach
terry candidat donc aux élections
municipales et communautaires de la
trinité c'est au tour maintenant dany
chargea mais allez-y à l'heure pour
surfer sur le changement parce que nous
arrivons parce que nous souhaitons ce
changement nous avons des constats nous
avons constaté des choses qui sont
partagées avec les habitants de trinité
nous l'alliance pour la trinité une
alliance forte riche de personnes de
d'horizons différents deux personnalités
différentes de tendances politiques
différentes
une liste ouverte qui ne partagent qu'un
seul but celui de porter la trinité et
de lui faire retrouver sa fierté parce
que nous sommes des personnes fières les
trinitéens nous aimons cette trinité et
nous rêvons vraiment c'est pas un doux
rêve de la voir surgir de la voir
renaître de ses cendres
et c'est vraiment de cela qu'il s'agit
je vais pas parler du maire je vais
parler de de demain
2 comment nous nous projetons nous
voulons vraiment que les quartiers qu'il
n'y ait plus de fracture entre les
quartiers le beau ça c'est une réalité
aujourd'hui nous avons vraiment un
problème avec les quartiers et le bourg
pour changer tout cela
j'évite les trinitéenne et les
trinitéens a tourné une page d'histoire
est apportée aux affaires une femme et à
faire que la trinité soit de nouveau
celle qu'on aime
monsieur li molle pour clôturer bien non
pour clôturer et parmi les projets
d'ailleurs il y en a un que nous n'avons
pas
on va dire abordé c'est celui de
l'hôpital de trinité moi je souhaite
maintenir l'hôpital de trinité à trinité
lorsqu'on parle de notre activité nous
avons certains dépendent de la nous
avons sélectionné projet la volonté
parce que nous sommes aussi un centre
administratif et pour autant dans lequel
s'inscrit justement l'hôpital de fini tu
es donc pour les trinitéens pour les
habitants du nord parce que nous sommes
aussi dans des élections communautaire
nous avons besoin de garder cet outil à
trinité donc maintenir mais surtout
sécuriser la construction du nouvel et
puis je veux aussi dire aux trinité
n'est autre qu'un terrain que je leur ai
promis d'en lors de mes passages dans
les quartiers que nous mettrons un lieu
de recueillement à trinité c'est
inadmissible qu'une vieille comme
dignité n'est pas un lieu de
recueillement et souza plan lieu comme
scénariste fait pour les leafs est gérée
depuis les salons ces joyeux voilà même
si nous en mettons un provisoirement
lorsque nous arrivons aux affaires nous
allons m c'est une demande de la
population
donc ce que je veux dire puisqu'on a
parlé du changement nous allons non
seulement c'est la conclusion nous avons
besoin d'une minute
voilà juste vous dire que nous allons
changer de nom pas changé de pansements
nous allons penser le changement à venir
voilà donc merci à nick charles heck
richard bartel riz et les olim hall dont
le tirage au sort l'avait désigné pour
terminer les confusions voilà et puis
nous rappelons avant de refermer donc
cette émission que j'ai eu le plaisir et
l'honneur de présenter avec alain livory
que le quatrième candidat donc frédéric
duval à caillé et les trinitéens
apprécieront le gall et qu'il n'est pas
venu jeudi charles délais indiqués la
calle moi je dis qu'il n'est pas là il
n'est pas venu chercher
je souligne surtout qui nous a donné
aucune explication vous voulez moi je
vous dis là
nous avons averti qu'il ne viendrait pas
et on ne sait pas pourquoi il n'est pas
venu c'est dommage mais trinitéenne et
les trinitaires ci avoue de mépris
pologne respectivement que le prochain
débat aura lieu vendredi
donc en radio web il sera consacré à la
ville des trois îles et alain dernier
mot non merci
le débat en télé vous savez pour mardi
ce n'est pas bon en temps utile merci
c'était une émission réalisée par cédric
berck les élections municipales le débat
[Musique]